tell me about having the original
American Idol on the show tonight Kelly
Clarkson there had so much fun having
Kelly there she was like a breath of
fresh air like I said you know just
confused all this energy into the panel
because her perspective is so different
than ours because she was actually on
the show and went through every single
moment and knows what every single
moment feels like except being sent home
we would all worried that she might be
ready to pop while she was up there no I
think she had a pretty under control
everything was okay she's still about
seven weeks out she says it was an
emotional night the emotions I mean I
think you know everybody realized you
know this is our top 10 our final top 10
of American Idol ever you know and I
think everybody all the contestants
could feel the weight of what was
happening and having Kelly there as well
and her being emotional because she said
she was pregnant but I feel like
everybody's emotional right now when it
comes to the show it's been such a
beautiful journey for everybody and to
think that it could be over you know
you've been watching the packages of the
contestants for me was like wow this
guy's singing the cows and now he's on
this is not going to exist anymore it's
crazy right and 15 seasons and there
have been so many different kinds of
judges and you've obviously been a fan
favorite for a long time how do you want
to be remembered in terms of your
judging style just that I was honest and
kind and you know try to impart as much
wisdom from being in the business as
long as I have to the contestants and
that you know the Cardinal will treat
others how you would like to be treated